like like I don't know why we deny
reality like this is just
saying every fat person
did I say every fat person no but you
basically said if you're fat go in the
bin that's your business I didn't
basically said that yeah nice words
look there are Exceptions there are
women that get bigger and they have a
nice shape
they're a personality can help sure but
what what percent of women today are
really that feminine what percent of
women today really know how to cook
really know how to cater to them not not
so you're gonna say oh well they could
have personality they could if women
were so good in the west why are men
getting Sports and leaving yeah for sure
and so when you come in and say hey like
you know I like big girls too it's like
it's sort of a wide women